so the reason I think it's a it's a
Supremacy movement is because we're
asking for freedom without the
responsibility even with the right to
vote it was the freedom to vote without
the responsibility of getting drafted
the responsibility of getting dropped
yes because if we go to war men get
drafted and then it's the same now as in
we have the responsibility to vote no
you asked you asked about first wave
feminism no I asked which I asked which
wave you were talking about and you're
saying you're talking about I said yes
because I think it's always been the
same movement it's always been a hate
groom it's always been a Supremacy
movement